when i got out here i was on i wanted to
drink party sex drugs all that [ __ ]
right and and i had heard dr dre
tell me california knows how to party
right
and then i got out here and i'm like all
[ __ ] dr dre
lied to me man california doesn't know
how to [ __ ] party california knows
how to [ __ ] shut down at two in the
morning no no [ __ ] you can't buy no
liquor you can't
like it's a you know
yeah it's a [ __ ] it's a joke i was
pissed i was basically making me go
outside to smoke my cigarettes
everything shuts down at 2am there's
nothing you got to go to someone's house
this [ __ ] like there's california on
that [ __ ] guy i was pissed
yeah i was gonna say that's crazy you
spoke drake cause i was just over dre's
house man a week and a half ago man oh
dear bro i'm not mad
one of the best people in the world man
not only that but i'm honored
for him to have me record something at
his house for his upcoming album that's
getting ready to come out unbelievable
yeah that's big to me man come on flavor
flavor on a dr dre album man
word look man that's big to me bro
that's huge dude that's huge and and you
know but but you said california you
don't know how to party because they
shut down that two o'clock
right and then you know you got
california shuts down at 2am new york
they're good til like four and in some
cases like five
you know and then there's vegas sin city
right but where i came from man i always
said dude if vegas is sin city then
miami's straight up [ __ ] hell
miami doesn't [ __ ] around dude
vegas makes a big deal out of it where
it's like you know it's like disneyland
for adults you know like come on
miami's just straight [ __ ] gnarly all
the time and they're not even [ __ ]
making a big deal out of it right right
right yeah i love miami though man i
love i love partying down there man they
got
got some good clubs down there and then
also i did my homeboy flow writer you
know
my real good friend you know what i'm
saying and uh
when i first started staying out here in
la and i was staying at a studio that my
boy devonte swing had devonte swing is
part of a group called jodeci and also
devonte is the one that did all the jody
sees music as well and he had a studio
and i used to stay at his studio and
this was before a flowrider went down to
florida and hit it big with po boy but
we used to stay together
yeah man we used to stay together me and
me and flo
and um
and then also another rapper
i i don't know if y'all can remember the
name but my boy
his name is kay solo
okay so right kay solo he had a
he was famous for a record called
spellbound okay yeah so we were all at
the studio together
you know
you know back to drake dude
like there was some when i told you
about that comedy special i made the
multimedia with all the [ __ ] crazy
stuff and i paid for everything and i
made it myself and i was like
and then i brought it and and and
everyone didn't want it like netflix
says uh no we don't want it like hbo and
all this and i was just like damn i was
thinking about how dr dre made the
chronic and he brought it around people
didn't want the chronic i was like you
know what [ __ ] these [ __ ] [ __ ]
what i made this is the [ __ ] i made
the [ __ ] chronic i mean you know i
was like let that kind of be my
inspiration and i didn't [ __ ] back
down i doubled down i [ __ ] put it out
of my i couldn't be more glad that i did
no doubt yeah dude and and i was trying
to like tell them to tell that to dre
you know other than i forget how how we
tried to reach out to him but uh how's
he doing man he's just he's getting
scared he's doing excellent
he's he's doing excellent man i went
over to his house man my first time
ever over at his house
man's doing excellent man he can't be
doing better that's great you know what
i'm saying i mean he did have a little
fall he did have a little fall where he
was hospitalized maybe a month and a
half ago or something like that but the
man came home and he's got a good
support team around him yeah at his
house
and that's what helped him get back up
on his feet come on man that man is
doing excellent right now jerry couldn't
be doing much no better that's great man
[ __ ] yeah
and dude you couldn't be doing much
better i'm trying steve i think you're
trying pretty i can't be doing much
better man come on man i'm on the stevo
show
yeah
yo man i'm a big fan of you bro dude
likewise man you know what i'm saying
and and i just wonder still to this day
how the [ __ ] do you make it through all
of this [ __ ] that you put yourself
through amazing dude
both of us man we've been at this for a
long [ __ ] time man and guess what we
got longer to go it ain't over we only
just begun
dead it's called stevo's hot sauce for
your butthole and if you go on amazon
and type in stevo's hot sauce for your
butthole and order yourself a bottle
you'd be really helping me because right
now we're ranked number 30 on all of
amazon and if you buy a bottle we might
go up the ladder and that would mean a
lot so please get on amazon and buy
stevo's hot sauce for your butthole
yeah
yeah dude